late starting here but they have this
ten-second tolerance period now playing
DD wet sir a guy i seem to have her
number of eight year and a half out of
23 yards i'm quite a number of games
okay let's just play conservatively now
let's go without them 95 ok let's go
without b5 m95 I'm at 93 put a vertex a
bit strange very uncommon way to develop
here in their way but of course not not
particularly bad or anything now just
going to develop they are threatening b5
here a little bit there should be three
Bishop takes a B it doesn't a CB doesn't
look like a rate structure the idea is
going to change the structure here ah
yeah what do I do here probably have to
check him then my bishop here looks a
bit strange but ok I can retreat this
type of position is not so bad i
recently had something like that in the
tournament game and actually I game that
i wanted to show on the channel at least
parts of it that could not yet i did not
yet managed to to I mean to analyze it
to a presentable level let's say yeah
arrow that looks very boring but I kind
of stumbled into this position I did not
want that it's a bit passive here
interesting yeah with this double porn
is why it's really what is this
interesting to understand the position
to be honest is this Jack I'm suffering
from space space problems IAM quite
clearly but i'm not sure about it the
double pawn wanted to provoke b3 i
thought that this is a good good thing
for me to get in ok well let's let's
just see what is this end game here i
can go 27 i mean it's it's almost like
this can come here the four against
three look more real to me than his
majority maybe I'm completely of them
but oh I don't mind that at all takes I
can't even go d5 huh let something okay
let's take first edits that's definitely
not a bad wolf and then think about it
three kings c6 as possible or maybe see
65 or defied immediately you have
immediately for capturing there but I
think Alex e65 that which may be sensors
came back to be three defending the beef
or pawn yeah there we go so let's do
this those these pants look okay now on
the on the light squares hmm how do I
continue knight on f6 it's not
not very sure about this what what am i
doing with the night like to reroute
that somehow maybe you for push up to f6
and night to g6 this kind of thing 95
okay so i cannot go 96cm
hmm let's see five maybe I completely
miss evaluated this end game that's
possible should f8 oh that looks like a
strange North f6 also not what I want to
do
Jeff but what what else and now I Ponzi
on dark squares hmm that sets it's not
good
yeah my asics pawn is weak but if he
let's say he wins it with a night and I
get to his King side on my D for e to F
for I would have plenty of pawns to
attack so it might still be okay in this
position and I might check here Knight
c3 and I can jump quickly to a form
check to f4 h4 h5 maybe tings tings
exactly I have to have to do that anyway
no use in thinking here without any big
incentive I have to do that getting
getting to the to the king society with
the noid and the question is however
maybe Knight f3 actually yeah Knight f3
491
still tough this position
no I guess 96 nah no no no no that don't
have a good square their time warning
check I can take with a night of course
that's that's just much simpler than
taking with a king I know how did I've
actually up this end game adjust it was
really ok from from the get-go then I
totally killed myself here ah black
resins now that was set was terrible I
mean here I never ever should use the
game never ever so before and so I take
what did i do long I mean losing its
really really bad from this position
white 32 wrong there is c65 may be wrong
it's possible maybe I shouldn't move the
pawn so quickly them
hmm i think c6 is good but i should not
probably not play d5 the moment the
spawns control important squares and d5
is giving up on c5
25 yeah maybe I just baby thats if it's
really bad I don't know Bank not a forum
Chim and at the end of sitting there
with the bad end game
which I think I should lose here I don't
know I don't think so my original idea
was to do this guy that was better I
don't know I really don't know it since
it's a kind of tricky this is what I
wanted to do originally this kind of
thing age four and then h5 was my idea
and white X yeah my night is offside
that's just the problem here my night is
off-site listen I this is a bad piece
check Jim no this is not this isn't
great idea for ik i can still draw
somehow technically but I shouldn't ever
get there in this kind of this kind of
situation here I'm just losing just
losing them so what what is it that I
should do here default check check yeah
activate king is 695 I never even King
d5 so that's not even great for what is
it that you should do maybe taking and
computers has equal but I really
shouldn't shouldn't get get down I was
really thinking that if anybody is
better here is me maybe I'm just too
optimistic as i often am but I just felt
like I have the better pawn structure
but may the dollar point isn't such a
big issue I mean I'm always in danger
that mere pawns end up on dark square so
it's probably probably more important
them oh well he won that game thanks for
watching